[Musik]
sind sie zweiter mit einem ass hens ich
sagen gewesen
und hens ist kühl wenn sie ihr hättet
werden sie den nachwuchs müssen
die erklärende worte spezial macht geld
glücklich
[Musik]
im berner oberland und da wohnte er mit
christoph trummer unterrichten sagt sie
erst ein glücklicher wohnung mit hecken
oder reifegrad wir mit hacken
[Musik]
er schätzt es am sonntagmorgen ist auch
nie verheimlicht
was mache ich denn glückliche darf ich
mich als das bisher noch steht das atmet
dass sie darin dass mir geht das macht
mich das ist glück
und liebe glücklich über das meer das
dass mich das glücklich macht
das ist glück
das metas gegriffen ich glaube dass ich
nicht verstehen
der durchschlag reichen zwischen
komplett andere weiter
die meisten gemacht haben andere für
dich selber einfach die linke die linke
sieht dabei die anderen aber die rechte
sieht wie die linke seite aus gesehen
wie mit der hund zusammen wie christoph
daum oder mieter ist ein reporter des
ersten zeugnisse nur zu finden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein leben im bachbett der ängstigen neue
flugticket im berner oberland allein und
ohne besitz
[Musik]
warum
was macht es mit
so
er ist einfach
sonys als frauen
neben
märz vor
chaos im land jetzt vorbestellen in
jahrelanger arbeit bei der sich ein
refugium auf einen ort des einfachen
lebens und hohen denken sagt er
ein kleines paradies für einen raum mit
wechselnden iv
historisches wunderbares wasser so
womit wieder aufs neue ja dort
gewaltiger und schon im blick
und navy nach dass frau im harz ist
einfacher schritte nach dem 11 mir macht
es einfach den kopf sind sie im kopf
trummer wusste schon als jugendlicher
dass er nie eine familie wollte er
wollte frei sein was noch lange nicht
heißt dass er ein kostverächter ist im
herzen sei und bleibe im april mit ein
einsiedler der mehr oder weniger
abgeschieden von den menschen lebt
es ist allerdings am gerät
konfrontiert
valencia gestaltbaren ziegel lappalien
zu ermöglichen
so
darüber machte sich mit anfang 20 auf
den weg um nichts weniger als den sinn
des lebens zu finden
über umwege landete er in indien wo ihm
alle seine sachen gestohlen wurden
für ihn ein zeichen alles loszulassen
also meldete er sich nicht bei der
schweizer botschaft sondern lebt die
monatelang auf der straße und war danach
ein anderer als er alles materielle
verloren hatte merkte er dass er etwas
gewonnen hatte freiheit fli franz
schrief existenzangst wie vor einfach
frei 24 stunden der tag offen machen mit
wurscht
niemand ist da der so präsenz auch nach
irgendwann nicht einfach frei ich mit
dir mit die mit der zusammen mit dem
harz unterwegs
darum wird sich das aber immer wieder
unter menschen etwa nach flüchtigen wo
er geboren wurde und wo er noch heute
ein winterquartier hat alaba das
verhältnis zu seiner inzwischen
verstorbenen mutter war nicht immer
einfach
er habe frieden geschlossen mit seiner
vergangenheit auch mit seiner
unglücklichen jugendzeit es wirklich so
weit geht dass die bibel sich das leben
so sieht das ja das ist klar
das nebenfach ging fiel felix sie aber
ihr bewaffneten aktivere tool free für
die gesperrte 2
drum stammt aus einer evangelikalen
arbeiterfamilie
er war das fünfte von sieben kindern
seinen eltern zuliebe schloss er eine
lehre als elektriker ab und machte die
rs dann braucht er aus bis nach indien
und als er von da zurück kehrte war aus
dem lieben buben ein junger mann
geworden denn seine familie kaum
wiedererkannte
er führt gerade das tut ja so tut als ob
kein findet auch für sie
schumacher ist handwerklich begabt ist
eine dienste sind in und um frutigen
gefragt hat dem staat deshalb noch nie
auf der tasche gelegen
er arbeitet allerdings muss so viel dass
er seine rund 500 franken fixkosten im
monat decken kann und nimmt nur aufträge
an die eher sinnvoll findet also ich
liebe das einfach aber ferro pflückt
spezialfahrzeug half und so das macht
sinn
unterwegs wird über die b45 dass ich
mich einfach beschreibt finanzielle
opfer machen
und immer schwingt oder störe für wien
im jahr
selbstverständlich kam ihr des tvb aber
nicht im sinn also privatstiftung mirko
vierte bradley und im vierten jahr
gestimmt als damit solle mittels steht
einkommenssteuer muss man sehr stolz auf
das existenzminimum abuja dass man mehr
verdient würde dass man durch das schon
richtig dass das richtig versteht wird
noch immer lebt roma im bachbett ist
kürzlich 64 geworden und sagt er sei und
bleibe glücklich
das glückliche sabine mit der schatz
vergraben die mit wenig dass der schatz
er ist schon glücklich aber zwar der
glücksritter scharfer und anwender
rabatte vor
es lohnt sich nicht
als hilfe
letztes jahr als amalgam zeitpunkt also
voraus
jeder hat uns bewusst erfahren
das paket sei aber grünes licht und
liebe oder der lit
das machte sich mehr als glück das ist
mühselig geht
die sorte glücklich war bisher bis
tisches auf eigene shows baut nur um die
kirche ja aber das ist doch nicht so
einfach im raum bezirke wurden rasch zu
handeln sagt das ist so will
wer jedoch wie jedes stück wird die
gruppe der augsburger was in diesen
spind hc stehen
familie h verantwortung über das ist ja
so wie du bleibst eigentlich nicht
möglich
das ist an sich mannschaften sollten
meisten sachen für gesellschaft
verschiedene klubs verständigt dass es
interessante der b26 klinikum das ist es
wird doch braucht das beispiel sky mit
zieht
zum zur lösung der machen damit sie mit
scania das geben was denkst du über die
menschen einfach meistens was
konventionell verlagert wo man karriere
machen wo ich mit der familie genießen
und einfach wäre spuren sind ja das muss
klappen versicherung verklagt
das ist das klappe zum fenster ist jetzt
auch noch noch nach besitzstreben
dies hat der cargo city muss muss
vergehen musste das potenzial war was
blickt das mit na und dass ich für
möglich
und was heißt das auf apple startet viel
schafft viel geld verdiene was ich den
job das ganzes epos la palabra schlafe
gesundheit und was spielt das la vie die
sich noch in und gut und gern nach dem
spiel treffen
das praktizieren die niemand dabei
erfolgt wenn durchlese angestrengt
worden
und was nimmt normalerweise wenn ich so
auch noch mal werwolf wenn er wir hatten
dann waren wir wohl der gesellschaft
nicht so begeistert dass mir jeder
schritt jetzt schaut auf pump mit
energie so anfangs mehrjährigen job
booms vom fuß autokran also sieht was
soll das ganze
er probiert einfach wirklich so für ein
fußabdruck
vielleicht ging mehrere fußabdruck also
nicht mitmache dann ganze wahnsinn ibena
von der normale mit dem fuß ab doch
energie spezifikum mir geht mobil
gegeben ist oder die x men wo irgend
demnach fehlt
warum sie ja selber gebeten
am hungertuch nagen nicht über die
verhältnisse du bist der einzige oder
weniger weder von der welle von weniger
ja interessante show das das was du
machst im moment absolut trendig es geht
überall minimalismus bewegung politisch
bleibe nur noch mit 4 6 gegen stein wo
achtsamkeit predigen was anderswo
duscher sie jahre lebt durch eigentlich
eine große karrieren als als kugel
machen als spirituelle führung
und im moment wird und die menschen aber
schon längst aber wird es viel einfacher
machen wenn ich die zahl brandschäden
cyndi lauper soll bis vorige woche
draußen sehen muss was lag aber mir
geht's so machst du so wie die anderen
als leiter lang an die fixe job kein
gewehr der pensionär wirklich echt
komisch mit zwei jungs mehr mist ganz
lange spaziergänge mit bild beim turnier
in der pensioniert wird der vorfall aber
das macht die natur bevor jetzt schlafen
lassen
naja und sohn ist gerichtet
er misst aber klappt wird klar
und es geht die vergangenheit das auf
die idee ist dass ich und zukunft
[Musik]
du hast kranken kfz steuer osterwasser
special creation im moment merke da
einige besucher der strom ein anderer
anführer oder total des inneren am berg
oder familien oft wild und herzlich sagt
evers ich glaube an drei geschafft mich
der user und jetzt wirklich schafft sich
als restaurant und hotel imperium
aufbauen
uns ist ein reporter der feststoff
franzen hat der aufschwung bleibt
das ist die rede der alb im oberwallis
für mich ein heimspiel
ich bin auf den benachbarten batman ob
aufgewachsen den erfolgreichen hotelier
bergführer und skiakrobaten art vor
kenne ich seit meiner kindheit aber
persönlich haben wir uns erst einmal
getroffen
[Musik]
so wie viele hier oben hat er auch ich
früher ein ambivalentes bild von ihm vor
er hat viel getan für die bekanntheit
des alle gebietes aber er hat auch gerne
und häufig gestritten und war einer der
hart austeilte ich möchte erfahren ob
ihn sein reichtum glücklich gemacht hat
jetzt wurde man mit dem cowboyhut 83
jahre alt ist und dann amerika nicht
danach richten einer dritter jahr immer
wieder sehr leicht und gut galtür
verdient und der erst egal hier aber
prüft verbote nachher eine agfa
vorschrift sehr viel von einer monika
verschollenen schwester amerikaner
verkauft dann immer wieder gehalt reflex
nächster und immer im leben immer
weniger geld eine biene sucht ist sie
stark stiegen und über die werke die
technik ja aber sehr trifft das
höchstens auf einer welt mit dem
schlüssel
und das wäre das da ist alles meine
fotokunst branche dass da ist der
langjährige wird der antarktis
ja so ist das sind die auch zusagt und
[Gelächter]
entweder das rezept aber das wäre oder
dass das alles abdecken ohne krippe hat
city magazin
als möglicher schönere aber kommt ist er
zuständig bis hin zu stellen hat zwar
einen großteil seiner immobilien an
seine drei kinder vererbt
aber er besitzt immer noch land und
wohnungen im wert von mehreren millionen
franken
hier sind wir in der wohnung seines
bruders gregor gysi das größte mal eine
komische magazins sie geht es immer noch
unter dem magazin da bin ich ja da lang
redakteur ein schweizer begeistert mit
seiner kritik am kalender ihr nicht
wisst was er noch persönlich bleibt
thema olympia medaille klein denken als
ich bei der olympiasieger die vorteile
hatten
in amerika sorgte mit seinem ganz
eigenen stil für furore
ein spaßvogel und klauen der nicht mit
kraft und auf tempo vor sondern locker
und verspielt so machte er die
skiakrobatik populär
[Musik]
der fordert prinzipiell alles was im
krieg verboten ist nur macht als so
perfekt dass alle lied ihn bewundert das
ist ja dank google und anarchie schoss
einzig immer mehr separat publikum kennt
der ist ja dass das dein ericsson im
regen und er hätte meister werden der
beste ja aber nicht nur zwecks eben
verdienen
der besteller 800 bis bis auch nur diese
million franken
ob das land kritisch oder aldi
österreich niemand endlich geld verdient
so viel war daher sein motto mehr im
nächst immer über alle weg sind und er
wirkt in vielen filmen und reportagen
mit hier mit hellem ausstand nennen
können dass das ballett und ressourcen
schaffen und das kommen sogar die
palette ist es normal sagt wenn das herz
geschlossen
sag mal eine doppel-chance spezielles
verdenken streeter dass das auge erklärt
dass der grund gilt der belegungsplan
deine liebe der opfer getan
herr koch ganz spezielles verhältnis
kann ich alleine zahlen 12 meine kamera
mutter verstieß dort groß und haben
der dompteur gesehen wenn er mit engerer
aber es hatte der komplette auspackt
[Musik]
vorher wurde zum aushängeschild von
großen ski ausrüster schnapsbrennereien
oder vom playboy und der maschine der
proms die kennedy familie doris day oder
leonard bernstein zählten zu seinen
kunden ein spieler der letzten jahre die
schweiz die nachfrage nach der
schützenbruder gebiet größer wurde
dann hatte den erfolg in die schweiz
gebracht wie das gästebuch zeigt noch da
ist der sohn vom nachlass tastan delle
der manager
der camcorder kann also ohne kompromisse
ja ja das ziel doch sie nahm er das
macht das hat das schon engagierte sehr
vermehren christoph indizes für familie
und 40 jahre alt ca
familie mit der familie eine case
problem kein weil meine frau hätte
familie klagt dass der beste motor was
keiner geht weiter ich bin nicht der
beste aber ich bei denen eine kollabo
und immer immer bei der familie
wirtschaft aktuell sehr viel erwachsener
kinder hat familie übernachten und ich
zum unternehmer blogger aber jetzt jetzt
früh die post immer mal wenn man das
wenn man es ganz genau
ganz gefordert wurde hätten
aber da waren wir zu klein ist bisher
fast ganz sicher etwas verpasst
aber da hat also verpasst das waren ich
geschafft habe jenes gebracht hat
einfach für familie kommt sie einen
bestimmten zeiten zu einem platz kam
klick klick klick macht sich jedes halbe
nicht programmiert und surfen sondern
klick macht man sich selber indem man ob
das will aber ob es wirklich will
behaltet berühmt ist mit seiner frau
gerlinde ist hier seit über 50 jahren
zusammen was er kommt von den bildern
und erdbeeren messerscharf sie im
fliesen es im kraft überhaupt aber es
genau das gegenteil müssen aber immer
voller abwechslung
voller spannung volles kampf sollte
zieht vom leibe wenn etwa kurzfristig
jetzt wird der korona problematik binnen
vier wochen hier und internet im
klartext sie so schön und so hoch wie
nie zuvor
eine mögliche karriere als skirennfahrer
seiner jugend am fehlenden geld
gescheitert
vor ort ist in bescheidenen
verhältnissen in dem bergdorf kreis
aufgewachsen
damals noch ohne seilbahn und
straßenverbindung
[Musik]
einige wurden
aber da aber herzlich
hier finden sich auch noch relikte seine
streitlust diese wird das wirtepaar das
blatt stand damals neben fotos
restaurant ein kleiner konkurrent doch
vor ort hinweg haben
formal ging es um eine fehlende
bewilligung daher hatte ich eine stelle
ohne eine bewilligung zahl also ich
finde das einfach nicht korrekt war es
etwas bringt sich gott heißt
juristisches problem sondern es manches
problem der abfuhr ich vorher nicht und
missgunst und alle liefere ich mit allen
mitteln das stimmt nur einfach gar nicht
wieder krieg hier oben auch wenn man das
projekt abgesegnet ist mit rickman dreht
metal um mit diesem jahr bekannt und
weil es den streit hat er damals mit
geld gelöst wurden und dann hält er kurs
verschärft dokument und der blogger und
der bezirksklasse meinte rische frieda
was ich bin zufrieden mit dem westderby
zurück hören sich oder stellt er sicher
nicht vergessen wusste nicht friede wird
viel ganz ganz wenig ganz wenige
sein vater war die jäger und wilderer er
starb jung an eine lungenkrankheit
arthur war damals erst 13 jahre alt und
doch sehr stark von seinem vater geprägt
wurden jährlich die im büro hängt görg
wasser und jungen ein sprecher aber wir
sehr ehrliche gebracht und das ist nach
dem wird bleiben und nach an einem auf
dem irak vor
eines tages will ich mindestens dass sie
die dann bricht wenn möglich mehr apa
sie nochmal immer galt als oscar aber
einfach
wir werden daher auch und jetzt war es
damals ja doch der erste bischof mit
abschluss hereinspaziert meister kopf
geschlagen dass durch eine genauso ins
register
da ist der großmutter das thema
großmutter trick sie bitte hier
da nicht grund da nicht gut und wenn ihr
aber so ist das vertretung so kann auch
hier ist nichts hält nix kann das muss
man das ist ich habe mir fast egal ob
tief der intrexx den markt gemacht sind
ein freispruch erster hersteller oder
und daher der jobcenter jetzt große
spiele machen wir das
es war ja auch da wird hier auch der
hunger der täter schlug ganz klar er
habe im leben fast nie eine
interviewanfrage abgelehnt seine
medienpräsenz ist seit jahrzehnten groß
dass er gefunden hat diese männer dass
sie korrupt
ich denke helfer darin soll das aber hat
er schon immer die klar darf doch das
wäre weil alle etwa daher war das
saarland macht der journalist dass die
damals etwas fällen sind die ferienwoche
das bisher gehabt weil bei dem entgehen
könnte es auch gemacht und westen nur so
krimmer von sa liste werden so und so
denn nach über hundert mal zu mir wenn
das ziemlich friedrichshagen
das hat der verkehrsteilnehmer zahle
sich zahlt das heim nicht mehr erklärt
wenn der playboy geschafft hat und dann
fragte wieso er so locker denn thema zb
vor daniela decker einige hätten wir so
wirtschaft macht und das doch gange
gesehen dass doch chris kenntnis aber
hinter machen ist natürlich riesig das
darf doch nicht dass man im bundesrat
der buchhalter oder wochen fertig macht
ja das salz ausgeht
das ist das geht doch nicht dass heim
nicht
um das rad nicht zuletzt habe ihm die
streng katholische erziehung halt
gegeben im leben wenn er nicht roth
fordert der religion hatte kam dass er
mal verteidigt dass man wieder so
wichtig weil immer mehr die kraft
genommen heißt es hätte hannes möller
das haben das aber kein verwandter mit
sind nur noch die besten organe hammond
zwischen dem eine normale druck oft alte
fotos scheint mir recht zufrieden mit
dem was sie im leben erreicht hat ob mit
geld oder den jungen jahren ohne ein
grundstein dafür waren die jäger weiß
halten die er von seinem vater gelernt
hat
kurzes konzept und funktionierten
[Musik]
geld macht nur glücklich wenn er mehr
abhängig mache
es sieht das half erlitten deshalb das
machen aber glücklich galt es probiert
nix mehr papier
ein wermutstropfen bleibt seine
nachkommen haben den betrieb der meisten
hotel & gastro betriebe kürzlich
eingestellt sie sind dabei teile des
erbes zu verkaufen wie es weitergeht ist
derzeit in abklärung
das wird das mit der hilfe wünschen aber
so das ist nicht unwahrscheinlich
wichtig der name vor und die hotelkette
die wird ja eine vergessene sie
[Musik]
macht geld glücklich dass walker madonna
und ein feld ist jetzt noch immer einige
sehen wir dass sie sich vor was ist noch
kein kommentar gern grad ohne ich bin
gespannt was die geschichte von marco
jetzt das leben angeschafft hat das
imperium aufbaute hinweis darauf wie
wirkt so eine geschichte oder schwarz
ist und natürlich die fahrt und tv über
gut fallada wie gut dass ein fallada die
straße tatsächlich wirkte gut
holländisch das problem und ich denke
glücklich sie sich schätzen im leben
gott gar nicht zum glück sehr wichtig wo
man das glück zur aber nicht im
gefängnis und dämonen vergangenheit dass
ich runter gehen um auf dass die frau
thomas muss man aktiv sucht findet
anders vorgestellt
ja jetzt schon recht und schon herrscht
muss ist genauso informiert die vorüber
ist bewusst zweiter
das glück dass muss man glücklich mit
seiner sicht die frage was muss ich das
problem ganz an bliebe oder ganz richtig
meistens stellt sich die frage gar nicht
will bleibt irgendwo dazwischen und
wissen reporter simon richten die
produziert zwei menschen wofür sich
selber um sekunden es geht um schluss
nicht um es entweder oder sondern es
geht um und symbole mittelberg zu über
stefan geist einstige kadermann heute
yogalehrer und stress coach vor allem
führungskräfte suchen seinen rat und
zeiten von corona forcierte den
fernunterricht und analysiert das
problem vieler manager aus ayurvedischer
sicht sie haben zu viel vom vorher
element menschen die eben sehr viel
feuer in sich tragen haben in der regel
sehr viel power sehr viel energie sehr
viel willen und sehr viel
umsetzungskraft und das kennst du
vielleicht auch im bekanntenkreis oder
in dem büro gibt menschen die die gehen
da einfach durch die kämpfen und die
haben sich ein ziel gesetzt und die
haben unglaublich viel energie viel
power und unglaublich steigen wählen um
diese ziele zu erreichen und diese
menschen sind eben oft so im konflikt
mit anderen mit situationen und eben oft
auch mit sich selbst und das zeige ich
auch in meinen beratungen menschen die
ich sehr viel feuer in sich tragen
bis sie nicht zufrieden ja
doch was sie an mir schätzen da ich eben
auch aus der wirtschaft komme dass sich
eben auch ihre situation verstehen dh
wir sind auf augenhöhe wir können da
miteinander sprechen ich verstehe ihre
probleme ihre nöte was sich oft
beobachte ist das wenn die
zusammenarbeit dann länger geht wenn wir
uns intensiver auseinandersetzen dass
die menschen die gerade eben auch sauber
sie am außen orientiert sind die sehr
erfolgreich sündige zum management tätig
sind sich auch langsam getrauen zu
öffnen
also das geht nicht darum jetzt die
spirituelle erleuchtung zu finden und
dann eben mich von allen materiellen
loszulösen und jetzt muss ich alles
kündigen und alles verkaufen und ich
lebe jetzt nur noch irgendwie im kloster
sondern ich kann natürlich wunderbar
mein leben weiterzuführen wenn ich in
bestimmten aspekten dort eben auf mich
achten was tut mir gut was sollte ich
vermeiden
marina post hat schon als junge frau
erkannt was sie vermeiden möchte so viel
arbeiten gut tut ihr dagegen das reisen
nun wird sie pensioniert und will die
welt umsegeln was soll's lag bei navis
roth das ist schon mal wichtig aber
immer mit meiner größe respektvoll mit
dem auto der andere dir vorhin schafft
wichtig die route steht nun testet sie
das equipment
suche nach netzwerk jetzt versuche ich
noch so gut und so und die haben eine
minute zwei minuten telefonieren das ist
mir denke ich will dass dort vor sehr
gut sein soll ich da ich würde mal im
verein abwickler zum sagen soll es
einige schauer ist der hsv für ihre
familie darin freundinnen von mir aber
der fina frage
so bezieht familie sind das eher dienen
ihr gefällt nicht klar nein
stefan geiste war erfolgreicher manager
bisher mit 40 eine hirnblutung hatte und
sein leben änderte geld verdienen will
er aber weiterhin heute jetzt in meiner
position ist mehr wenn es ums materielle
geht schon auch ein gewisses einkommen
wichtig dass ich mir auch bestimmt
bestimmte dinge leisten kann aber ich
konsumiere sie anders das ist der punkt
ja aber damals natürlich konnte ich
nicht einfach sagen ja dann bist du
stolz oder ist es nicht mehr wichtig und
so ich habe da lange lange daran
festgehalten lange lange aber auch lange
wirklich versucht in der situation wo
ich bin etwas zu ändern was ja auch
schon eine lösung sein kann aber dann
kam ich zum schluss für mich nein ich
kommen möchte aus diesem sehr
kompetitiven sehr sehr
wettbewerbsorientierten umfeld wo sie in
vielem rendite um gewinnen um
gewinnmaximierung und so weiter und so
weiter kann mich da nicht mehr
eindringen das hat nun es war ein langer
prozess und das hat mich natürlich auch
vor große herausforderungen gestellt
ganz klar wie verdiene ich geld und bin
gleich zeit die glücklich
auf diese frage ist er ist mit 40
gekommen ich war jetzt 13 jahre in der
schule habe ich fünf jahre studiert
haben und zwei jahren ich war fast an
sicherheit schulsystem drin da hatte ich
kein einziger lehrer professor gefragt
stefan du möchtest du leben und da ganz
spannend ist dass ich zeigen dass ich
mir jetzt gerade ganz spontan
eingefallen über ganz weil wir über
krieg reden
ich weiß ja was gesehen hast beim
reinkommen immer nur so viel arbeiten
dass es für die nächste reise reichte
das war jahrzehntelang das leben zum
glücks motto von marina post will das
auto so schön ist wenn du auf die
sächsisch wind war schön vollen karibik
ist so falsch
aber das mache ich genau so blöd in
verschiedene schill und de facto wird
sein richtig warm reise das ist
besonders machen und zwar bis sie dort
um voll vom meer ist glück eigentlich
keine beobachter aber andere menschen
andere kulturen und dass der mit
befriedigen und befriedigung heißt für
mich auch glück glücklich sein
ich bin nicht der meinung dass es darum
geht jetzt nur die spirituelle
erleuchtung zu finden bin ich jetzt in
die höhle gehe und meditiere das kann
ich schon machen wenn ich jetzt im
himalaya groß geworden bin oder wenn das
jetzt meine aufgabe ist aber meine
aufgabe hier im zentraleuropa ist eine
andere und daher brauche ich schon einen
gewissen finanziellen wohlstand den
definiert für mich beobachte menschen
oft die diese sehr klare antworten immer
haben welche so absolute antworten und
ich glaube das leben ist komplexer und
vielschichtiger und das entscheidet
jeder für sich im zimmer haben zwischen
geld und glücklich schaut wissenschaft
auf der spur und einer wo sich intensiv
mit dem thema glück beschäftigen das ist
mathias binswanger professor für
volkswirtschaft glücksforscher direkt
druck macht geld glücklich wenn ich kein
geld hatte machen geld sehr glücklich
wenn ihr aber frank im spital liegt und
viel geld so hatte man ohne geld
überhaupt nicht glücklich denn eine
andere problem völlig auf situation wir
korreliert denn der wachstum von der
wirtschaft mit diesem glück also jetzt
mal zum beispiel ab zweite weltkrieg ist
sie beruf werz gang wirtschaft was sie
mir dann habe ich mein glück
es gibt länder wie usa oder japan doch
immer sogar zu aller sieht der fünfziger
jahre und da silva menschen sind genau
gleich glücklich oder unglücklich
zweiter 50er jahre
sie sind das heißt es gibt auch kein
zusammenhang zwischen steigendem
einkommen im durchschnitt und auf der
anbieter von glücksempfinden vor der
menschen
das gilt aber wirksam nur verhör
entwickeln die länder ländern ist das
nicht der fall
grundsätzlich folgendes beobachte dass
er hoch entwickelte länder wie der
schweiz oder menschen im durchschnitt
immer glücklicher werden mit noomi
kommen und auch als eigenes fach ab
sommer durchschnittliche nie kommen die
länder bei 20 dollar im jahr
das heißt länder unterhalb von der
einkommensschwelle liegen
dem durchschnittlichen einkommen führt
wirtschaftswachstum dazu hat das
management liegt das wieder werden die
länder wie der schweiz sowie die
oberhalb von dem schwellenwert liegt
dort führt im durchschnitt bekommen
immer dazu dass menschen auch glücklich
oder zweiter werden
was liegt das das liegt daran dass wenn
man natürlich mal die grundsätzliche
bedürfnis dass wenn dir steckt sind das
heißt das dach überm kopf das den
zunehmend andere sachen zentral werden
für das glück von menschen schon immer
unmittelbar mit dem ich komme zimmer
hängen
aber wenn wir natürlich darauf dass sie
da auch sehen dass es noch ein bis zwei
gibt und das ist dass das land wenn man
denkt dass der trierer menschen immer
glücklicher sind als die arme menschen
und das heißt es wird zunehmend eben
auch das sogenannte relative immer
wichtig und auch wenn ich nirgends habe
ich mir relativ egal was andere machen
da wir schon mal selber genügend a wenn
ich aber so reiniger mal was wollen wir
nie grund wird die offene steckt hat
empfangen die natürlich alle links
rechts oder was sind denn die anderen
also oder und den hand natürlich das
glück auch stark davon ab wie viel haben
die im vergleich zu anderen auch eine
damit teilt damit den standards gelten
also zum 1
der reiche griechen sind
glücklicherweise die arme zum anderen
zeige trotz stiegen der wirtschaft werde
ich mir gleich eine glückliche ist es
kein mädel stück ja dass sie erwähnen
widerspruch aber man hat natürlich keine
haben von der bi spiel kurz illustrieren
oder das haben wir das fußballspiel
vorstelle wo alle zur schauspieler
sitzen beobachtet jetzt gibt es einen
exit gut wie er sitzt hinter aber groß
sind jetzt aber drauf seid doch ein
vorteil gegenüber anderen sie etwas da
passiert ich habe glück verhalten aber
mehr beinfreiheit dass das kein
langfristige gleichgewichtszustand ist
entweder wird erzwungen sofort wieder
hinsetzen oder so schön sofort andere
hinter ihm auf links rechts neben ihm
jetzt stürmt plötzlich alle sind alle
auf ein höheres niveau
trotzdem netzsituation verlieren ob
verbessert oder wieder die große gut die
flieger sind schlecht das heißt alle
sind die verhörer sni wochen
trotzdem hätte vor der einzelnen
situationen verbessert und dass ich
genau gleich beim rallye kommen denken
viele tätigkeiten die beschäftigung
machen denn besonders glücklich menschen
sind grundsätzlich glücklich meistens
wenn soziale funktioniert das heißt
glücklich im moment und mit anderen
themen ist mit anderen e bis h lachen
nicht permanent es geht auf ihr hobby
ist das womit er macht warum rey macht
aber die meisten menschen auf dauer alle
geliebt doch wenn sie nur weil er ja bis
macht es einfach spaß macht ihm drei
junge andere zeigen was man jetzt da
gemacht hätte und massage seit er das
geld wieder so wenn es sozial aber gut
funktioniert denn sind das meistens
glückliche menschen wie der mensch ist
kommen sagt herbert ihr und dann ein
einsamer tiger im dschungel auf die
abgeschaffte ganz viele ganz
herzogenburg ich werde zu mehr geld für
jene dass wir jetzt denkt sie dass lee
widersprechen oder mit anderen zusammen
das widerspricht dem ziel will den
häufigsten auf das feld will man sich
entscheidet über vorwärts oder besser
zwei jahren karriere will mache
kreuziger tatsächlich sozialleben und
vertreter und dann merken wir erst
zeitlich verzögert das war ja noch gar
kein freund hat und das soziale bei nach
gar nicht so toll ich selbst war immer
ganz tolle haus wohnt und dabei viel
leid und tolle auto fahrrad denfeld dann
ist genau das also die wissenschaft
gezeigt wird sind im verhältnis zur
weniger heinz glücklicher geschützt als
in der schweiz speziell diesem land wenn
man aber zu denen gehört wohl weniger
hin wie lebt man einen reporter
christoph ranzen der stellt zwei frauen
vor womit weniger menschen
einst hatte sich daniel graf jeden traum
erfüllt
ein eigenes tierheim und sogar ein pferd
aber unglück und gewalt warfen sie
zurück jetzt verdient sie sich überleben
unter anderem als verkäufer in einer
straßen zeitschrift
[Musik]
es hat hier lebt sie mit wenig geld in
einem tollen land das fleisch und
funktionen kleidung für omar sosa als
und annika graf lebt zusammen mit ihrer
19 jährigen tochter die eine schwierige
zeit durchmacht und auf ihre
unterstützung angewiesen ist
die zweizimmerwohnung für rund 1000
franken miete fand sie dank bezieher ein
glücksfall für eine wie sie ist die
wohnungssuche ein spießrutenlauf
79 abs internet tore und weiß genau ob
es hatten sich 300 darf sie nur sie und
wenn es gut 210 wir das doch daran und
sagen ist sie bereit und und damit eine
spieluhr geo aber dann heißt gekommen
und so geht's meistens nicht aus der
coiffeursalon haarscharf von stephanie
schaub im thurgauischen amriswil ist
wieder offen
aber corona und lockdown sind nach wie
vor zentrale themen sind es immer noch
schaffen ist mist
[Gelächter]
am 17 märz musste salou besitze den
stiefeln ist schaut ihr geschäft
schließen
auf anordnung des bundesrates es folgte
eine zeit der unsicherheit und des
bangens ums überleben ihres ladens aus
heiterem himmel fielen alle einnahmen
weg aber die ausgaben blieben für miete
versicherungen schuldzinsen und den
alltag reserven hatte sie fast keine
[Musik]
konto- vielleicht diese fragen kann ich
mir auch an überlege zahlt die
versicherung manchmal leid ich alle
zahlenwerke will zum zahlen aber ich
handelt
daimler verloren die geldsorgen von
daniela graf sind kein ausnahmezustand
sondern alltag
die obdachlos oder so dass nicht mehr
viel geld heuer werden wir schon mit dem
feld können wenn sie denn wirklich zu
erkennen
rund 1500 bis 2000 franken verdient graf
monatlich diesem baseler fachgeschäft
für ein bedarf hat sie ein kleines
pensum als verkäuferin der laden läuft
aber schlecht
die kunden kaufen lieber in deutschland
oder im internet es droht der jobverlust
partnerschaft und ihr chef michael
büchler versuchten auch graf so lange es
geht auf der lohnliste zu behalten
er kennt ihre schwierige situation für
schweizer verhalten ist wird die sage
ist die ente arm ja aber sie lebt
wirklich öko es ist trotzdem sehr
aufgestellt sie ist sehr positiv und sie
ist es nicht apropos yamaha
[Musik]
der crafter sano von stefan schaum in
amriswil hat den corona lockdown
überlebt und ist seit ende april wieder
offen
ich glaube daher wird für alle ja
gewollt
die burg wird aber in der schweiz oder
im ausland deutsche ali t
ok trotz finanzieller engpässe werden
der korona zeit geld sei weiterhin nicht
das wichtigste in ihrem leben bin ich
halt immer so im luxus neuen auto die
zwei oder vier verschiedene autos und
richter werteten jedes jahr illegal geld
oder erfahrung glückliche stunde und da
stadtbaugeschichte doch immer als dass
sie viel mehr geld auf dem konto hat
sicherheit und mehr hatte dass claudia
das andere ja das schon
naja dass es dank des wieder krise gut
glück sieht sie aber vor allem darin
anderen menschen helfen zu können
vor allem solchen die auch traumatische
gewalterlebnisse hatten begleitet
[Musik]
corona virus das trifft auf wie zur
wirtschaft hart konjunkturforscher die
prognostiziere diese ziemlich natürlich
die rezession konjunktureinbruch stören
aber die werden und auf der anderen
seite stiegen
dafür sind ausgaben für soziales wie
wirkt sich jetzt das mag ich bin sagen
wie wirkt sich jetzt darauf die
glücksindex von der schweiz aus
40 werke des index von der schweiz
andere länder
und wir werden wahrscheinlich im
nächsten aber genau die gleiche menschen
sie wenn man jetzt sind das heißt dass
ich keinen großen einfluss tätige
kurzfristige intrigen in der wirtschaft
das ist nur was tun also für mich ist
der stunde noch für sie nicht der halter
schon mit der stimmung nach wie immer
lateralen damit rechnet dass man relativ
schnell aus der krise wieder ursache mit
wenn jetzt die längerfristig beratung
hätte das schon weh aber alles wieder
aufwärts das ist kurzfristiges phänomen
sie vor panik
das hat einen nachhaltigen einfluss auf
slick von der menschen glücklich gottes
gericht sein wenn die arbeit selber
gewählt
das heißt wenn ich mich selber
entschließe ich wähle
gewisse richtung verzichten will mehr
materieller besitz nicht so wichtig ist
den kataster quelle von glück sie wenn
wir aber damit aufschwung wird durch
äußere umstände der macht damit meistens
greift heute und wenn wir jetzt geht das
ja aber die arme menschen die sie in der
zentralen also glücklicherweise den hang
das mit der besonderen 10
das teammanagement unglaubliche
fähigkeit hand aus wenig viel zu machen
sie versteht er was sehr gut ist ein
weniger geld wo sie als glückliches
lebensgestaltung mehr sind umgekehrt
weltmeisterin länder mit der schweiz wo
es viel wenig zu machen aber trotzdem
letzter
obwohl man nach der hohen materiellen
wohlstand leben geben ist seliger denn
nehmen statt sind es so in der bibel
stimmt das macht wieder greifen geheilt
glücklich was zuerst einmal hart auch
wenn kein geld da ist das zwischen
anspruch nehmen wenn wir noch viel geld
ja ich das zum teil so markiert dass man
wirklich mal bis positiv habe wie yoga
mit dem geld wo man gibt oder weniger
glücklich macht dann ist das einfach ein
selber glücks quelle
wenn raab auf der wäsche dass wir
ständig nur gibt wenn er bis über und
den konkreten schnell denn abermals
schnitzt vor
und das machten aber unbedingt das buch
dauert bis die balance zwischen ge und
juli kann man mir ein mensch gesehen wo
frei grasen die ponys auf dem raser hat
ist das jetzt exzentrik war so meine
multimillionär
das ist für kinder sehr viel mit den
boni so rosenberger hinten muss ich noch
nie gesehen und ich denke das ist ein
teil wird bliebe du bist jetzt sind es
endlich mit abstand steht darum die
frage das ist toll
muss ich da am richtung richtung alte
schwester wurde ihm vom vorrichtung man
so zu nennen
ich finde das ist sicher eine abnahme
ist situation im garten aber wer viel
geld hat man aber große verantwortung
und teil wieder druckjobs anschafft das
ist ganz trauen also frage ich wo junge
und freunden ist den boxen hat man sogar
schriebe minimal sind
die schweiz umgezogen und ein junger
gott keine zahlen und das ist schon sehr
tief verwurzelt von ihnen vor der
situation wo man damals kaffee kalt und
wenn in schwierigen verhältnissen muss
aber vor allem die die regeneration
sagte sawicki wurde ich das so schlimm
bis 7 ich darf jetzt teil herrscht das
riesige grundstück sehr stoß so viel auf
die schippe als trainer wurde ich frage
dich sehr glücklich ihre soul bis funk
stehen ja jetzt eine strikte form sind
und freuen sich die menschen für mich
ist sie das wenn man der situation von
mythos clipfish denkt man irgendwo in
einem in der tribühne selbst sicherheit
der arbeiter das ist eine situation wo
ich weiß noch bis 25 sport meine musik
know how und und aufgemacht haben immer
noch das land hat ist man nicht
beantworten am körper nur angst habe ich
immer wieder die situation in davos wo
wir aber mutig seite vor der kasse ihr
sei es der frau ist es ein buch schrieb
war wirklich sehr sehr beklemmend
endlich ausgeliefert sie ratlos
dass das viel annika bis sie doch wie
bitter bereuen für 20 und das ist eine
art ritual das die situation menschen
juli habe das zu einem vermögen von
mehreren hundert millionen franken
gebracht
sein start ins leben war allerdings
schwer er kam als uneheliches kind einer
16 jährigen kellnerin zur welt und wuchs
in heimen auf
trotzdem schaffte er einen fast
märchenhaften aufstieg meist ist flur im
laufschritt unterwegs er eilt von termin
zu termin von erfolg zu erfolg
was er anfasst scheint ihm zu gelingen
nicht wenn die stiege
aber nicht viel falsch machen und so
einfach vorher
dann wäre der vielitzer folglich wie sie
aber schon vorsichtig mit der fall
es gibt sehr erfolgreich das ist sicher
so verschafft
aber ich würde jetzt nicht behauptet
dass ein
als großes talent das würde ich jetzt
also nix das ist jedes größte dollar
ganze
fluri war ein schulversager besonders
schlecht war ihm rechnen
besonders gut ist der unter anderem bei
immobiliengeschäften womit er mit anfang
20 mit geliehenem geld anziehen
zum beispiel in der zürcher innenstadt
also das wäre eigentlich die dann
bereich wo man den staat xwb
eigentlich mehrere gebäude der ziele der
seestraße droht hartz iv sieht wo die
objekt über noten sind lassen sie doch
in west java sich um die vier millionen
gesehen und gebäude gewartet
eingestiegen ist ruhe in den 90er jahren
mitten in der immobilienkrise auf alle
verkaufen wollten kaufte er irgendwann
erholte sich der markt die preise
explodierten und flur wurde reicher und
reicher
von uri engagiert sich schon lange
karitativ 30 prozent seiner gewinne
fließen in die kita fluri stiftung
davon profitieren unter anderem menschen
mit hirntumoren in diesem fall ein
mädchen aus brasilien das er zusammen
mit den eltern in die schweiz geholt hat
um es in einer privatklinik von einem
star chirurgen operieren zu lassen
[Musik]
auch für all die menschen die in der
schweiz im zwanzigsten jahrhundert opfer
von behördlicher willkür wurden
engagiert sich fluri unter dem titel
administrative versorgung wurden die
grundrechte von betroffenen
jahrzehntelang systematisch verletzt
lange wehrte sich die politik gegen eine
ernsthafte historische aufarbeitung und
wie es eine finanzielle wiedergutmachung
weit von sich
[Musik]
das änderte sich unter simonetta
sommaruga aus vorsteherin des
justizdepartements die politik war unter
druck geraten weil die topmodel über
100.000 unterschriften gesammelt hatte
für eine initiative die wiedergutmachung
forderte die schweiz entschuldigt sich
offiziell und sprach einen
solidaritätsbeitrag von 25000 franken
pro opfer
damit endete ein jahrzehntelanger kampf
flures engagement geht weiter kürzlich
ist darauf die griechische insel lesbos
gereist und hat das flüchtlingslager
moria besucht die zustände entsetzen ihn
er will versuchen und diesem elend etwas
zu ändern
unsere rolle und wie viele hier wird
doch in ordnung
noch eher war es nicht die mannschaft
wenn die energiehändler schaffen und bis
bewege sie nie einen integrierten blick
genommen ist eine verwahrloste hütten
inland ja ich habe immer noch mal
betonen dass ich versage vor der politik
zum multimillionär
eine klientin die idee als ein dicker
strich schaffte als eremit selbst weilte
armut lebt im berner oberland und hab
ich schon vorweg nehme während bei mit
lag er 2 1 drei sekunden vor dir
eigentlich wissen ich gespürt dass
labour vom von christof domrös eremit
was wird ihr zu zeigen
ja was mich erzählt er habe falsche
linie die stufte da die lockerheit die
freiheit wie die rinne gespült zwar
unter druck sackten rücken aber nicht
jetzt nur geld wenn ich frei habe sich
alles kaufen ja dann hätte man ansprüche
da spreche ich war wirklich auf jeden
fall für das mini täter betrifft das
schaf verantwortlich aufdruck bis
realisiert aber ich finde wenn man so
früh ist ja dass er da muss ich sagen
dass ich das leider gestaltet
ja ich weiß jetzt selber das heißt das
gefühl wie anderswo und behandelt da wo
du zur arme gehört und jetzt wo du zu
der zu der riege körpers merkst du dass
menschen anders mit ihr umgehen
selbst endlich frau mit der zitrone oder
womöglich als klugheit ja dass das
funktioniert sowieso nicht mit dem boot
dass man immer wieder das gefühl
vermittelt und der bisher das hat
natürlich auch gehört da wollen wir dir
die voraussetzung für eine mit bruchteil
der studie um körner zu machen
aber der mut hat man eine andere
situation hat mir hat meine kann nicht
mehr aufmerksamkeit und das ist aus
heutiger parallele dazu wenn man im
lager des erwacht und sich bis greife
denn hätte mir mehr könig also in
schwierigen verhältnissen hinab
wie ich es bei dir merkst du das auch
dass du sprichst gehören über wunsch was
wohl etwas sagen dafür ein ja ist es
klar dass klar ohne betroffen die armee
die natürlich als händen vor delego und
die tomaten stähler und und als damals
heute sind wild einfach nicht mitmache
schafft's built buses nicht stören nicht
krank gekostet sagte sozial ding ist er
schon und da wachsen so will hp nun ihr
motto italien der schweiz 5
wir haben sie in der beging
selbständiges unklar diffus und relativ
[Gelächter]
günstig also das problem dass zu
unterhalten ist ja nicht viel oder man
macht wenn jetzt geld glücklich frage
sein ding macht geld glücklich ist oft
nicht sinnvoll
als lebendiger laschewski macht
glücklich wie soll ihr geschäft versteht
oder gibt toyota und seine cdu
christlich eine box einbiegen wollte bog
eine predigt der kloster und der tee ist
so irgendwas nutzt die wird die ganze
welt kronach ist wenn du dir liebe nicht
hast und das ist klar das ist ob du
jetzt der fisch millionen hessen spürbar
girolamo millionen klicks spruch den
hals oder mit dem flip und export im
harz ist da viel wie mit familien mit
allem galt mittelgeber jeder flori hast
du überhaupt zum das glücksempfinden der
weiß das glück wurde heißt das privileg
ein stück zieht also für möglich dass er
das abschalten und das regeneriere ja
dass das kann ich einfach gut ich harre
generieren aber regenerieren heißt ja
immer nur wird das noch schaffen
richtiger großer wenn resultat wenn
wirklich ein fokus wird schon der
bereich soziale bereich wirtschaftlich
sozial dass man heute über der richtung
von mir erwartet aus beispiel indem man
einfach vollgas geben
da muss knallhart und und irgendeine
antwort die gewinne für dich sagt wie
die situation in der pflicht zu hause
irgendeiner die tribute für bezogen
ich bin irgendwo an der grenze nach oben
da muss man damals machen dass köthen zu
hören da ist es wert das ist es nicht
wert
italien hat die ihnen vom nabu bittet im
bild vom luxus der zeitschrift solche
energie cottbus bewirken für die
richtige ist grünhaupt herzlichkeit
funktionieren hintergrund von youtube
wunsch christoph trummer wenn du es dass
rusal was denkst du da konnte man schon
logisch dass strache einer dünnen und so
über die sofort große wohngemeinschaft
machen kommune hier die news kate
alternative gar ausnahmen etwa so groß
galt ökologisch natürlich ist das
vertretbar was das fbi griff mit der
partnerin ich so meine große liebe
diesen sport zu denken
jeder fluri wenn du jetzt wieder an der
schwerter ages quilter verspricht
glücklich
das schwierig also wenn man aufbaut und
mit denen weder von grund rufen es auch
welche die situation hineinversetzen
schwierig zu beantworten ja ja das wäre
ganz schwierig für mich aber danach lief
es stimmen erreicht hat die ganz sicher
jene soziale themen und wo man habe
wirken mit dem geld wenn man ein
bisschen veränderungen bewirken dass
dieser große genugtuung und technisch
das plötzlich neben mitteln um die
zuhörer bis zu bewegen
das ist nicht ganz einfach ja es gibt
momente wo ich sehr glücklich bin sein
wenn meine frau mich immer haben die
schweizer autor eine sehr glückliche
momente das ist ja bereich unabhängig
vom geld ja das ist nicht abhängig von
gartner im moment sicherlich schön im
fond du bist jetzt gemeinsam das
warschau in berlin aber morgen wo meine
frau aneinander
ich danke da momentan anders gespielt
als ich glück für einander da sie ja das
ist eine schöne moment nicht auf du bist
du glücklich sehr glücklich dass ich das
labor das hat der fahrerkabine ist hat
er erfahren dass lappe und vor allem das
italo svevo liebe das ist jetzt
großstadt lokal ich das einfach draußen
steht news und kann ich heute dass ich
das glück sehr viel dasselbe dass ich
später
doch wie viel oder wie wenig brauchen
wir tatsächlich zum glücklichsein einig
neun zimmer da die kommentarspalten
dokfilm über minimalist menschen sich
bewusst die schränke und zum beispiel
mit 64 gegenstand lebendigen einfach
durch youtube kanal abonnieren und
glocken aktivieren
auf dem laufenden danke fürs interessen
und bis bald